meine these die dienstpflicht ist
freiheitsentzug ich habe es hier eben
schon angemerkt bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier hält es für eine
grandiose idee menschen in deutschland
für einen gewissen zeitraum zwangsweise
in den dienst der gesellschaft zu
stellen jetzt kommt keine besonders
große überraschung linken-politiker bodo
ramelow ja auch der ist wie die soziale
dienstpflicht für junge menschen die
schulen sei schließlich auch ein zwang
er frage sich deswegen mal nicht da noch
ein jahr mehr dazu definieren können
auch berlins bürgermeisterin franziska
giffey so natürlich nicht für eine
überraschung sie hätten sozialen
pflichtdienst für sinnvoll sie sagt wir
leben in einer veränderten zeit und
vielleicht gehört zu zeiten wenn da auch
dass jeder junge mensch ein jahr für die
allgemeinheit aufbringt das klingt ja
jetzt ja nett dass gutes tun für die
allgemeinheit aber lassen sie es mich
einmal vereinfacht ausdrücken die
dienstpflicht ist freiheitsentzug wir
brauchen eine zeitenwende die
zeitenwende zurück zur freiheit die
zeitenwende dahin dass es individuum im
mittelpunkt steht nicht die gemeinschaft
es gibt nicht schützen wertes als die
freiheit des individuums und der staat
sollte nicht mehr macht bekommen sondern
sich endlich wieder aus dem leben der
menschen zurückziehen und jetzt freue
ich mich ganz besonders darauf was georg
k frau dazu sagt ich bin weder ein
verkappter kommunist noch ein verkappter
rechtsradikalen und haben doch wissen
kommt natürlich habe ja nicht nur
kommunistischen partei entschuldigen sie
bitte ja müssen wir das programm lesen
da wissen sie bescheid also den
kommunisten oder rechtsradikale ich bin
nicht beides aber ich bin dafür dass
junge leute auch nicht nur fordern
können sie wachsen einer freien
wohlstandsgesellschaft auf und die
haltung unserer viele anzeigen auch die
umfragen ist mit einer enormen förder
haltung und vorne haltung gegenüber dem
staat ich will alles und zwar sofort bin
aber nicht bereit wenn es nicht mal im
eigenen nutzen dient etwas für die
gemeinschaft zu tun mit dieser haltung
hätten wir wieder die bundesrepublik
deutschland nach dem kriege aufgebaut
noch könnten wir die probleme dagegen
wird meistern ja so dienstpflicht und
zwar aus zwei gründen kann denn die
jungen leute nicht für alle ja ich bin
immer der begriff junge leute so
schwierig vor allem wenn er von eltern
bekommen haben
ja ich bin jetzt auch schon 29 werde im
august ihr langes arbeiten im grab aber
nach dem abi
sieht er nicht hergab freuen wenn sie
sagen die jugend sondern nur da muss ich
sagen was ich für die jugend erlebt habe
in der korona pandemie die
leidensfähigkeit für alte menschen haben
die sich zurückgenommen obwohl einer
wissen sie also wissen sie ich bin sehr
dafür sozusagen
verärgert wenn sie so ein wort bemühen
die leidensfähigkeit wo fängt denn bei
ihnen leiden an dass man nicht in die
disco gehen kann
ja aber sie konnten in die schule gehen
und sie waren nicht ja gut ich bin gegen
die maßnahmen gewesen ich persönlich
aber gleichwohl rechnen sie doch nicht
von leiden weil wenn man ein bisschen
ausgangssperre display werden angeblich
hier in großer virus herum läuft ich bin
der auffassung leiden ist ganz was
anderes wir haben eine verzerrte die
junge generation die mit einer
erwartungshaltung durch die kante läuft
dass einem übel wird mit dieser
generation wie sie heute ist hätten wir
den nachkriegszeit nicht bestanden dass
die massnahmen gar nicht leidend war für
die jungen leute selbstverständlich
waren die leiden also ich glaube wenn
doch jetzt hier mal also und wirklich
butter bei die fische also was ist es
denn gewesen wenn ich heute 18 bin oder
17 bin mein abitur gerade macht wir
denken an den ersten kuss die erste
reise ohne eltern die abifeier die abi
fahrt natürlich sind das prägende dinge
die hatten wir alle die sind alle wegen
der pandemie ausgefallen ich habe viele
der maßnahmen auch für völlig überzogen
gehalten aber noch einmal ganz kurz dazu
also ich glaube wir haben momentan eine
generation dieses hoch politisch hoch
engagiert das mag uns auch nicht immer
passen das sage ich dazu aber sie gehen
auf die straße sie engagieren es war für
mich zum beispiel aber auch so wenn man
im politischen gespräch ist die kollegin
wird sicherlich auch bestätigen können
man kriegt viele anfragen von jungen
menschen und wir dürfen eines nicht
vergessen die erziehungsaufgabe haben
die eltern und nicht der staat jetzt
zusagen über eine dienstpflicht sollen
sie sozusagen noch ab
insofern ordnung reinbringen als wir
hier eigentlich zwei themen
gegeneinander diskutieren die eigentlich
erst mal gar nichts miteinander zu tun
haben weil die dienstpflicht hat mit
corona gar nichts zu tun wir haben doch
jetzt will sie haben wir haben nur
gerade einen zeit eine zeitliche
korrelation und ich würde ihnen ja zu
stimmen dass ich habe auch für kinder
und die durch die korona zeit gebracht
und insofern weiß ich dass kinder auf
viel verzichtet haben auch jugendliche
ich habe auch einen sohn der kein abi
hat ihn ja
weil dort nur um diese generation
sondern es geht ja das grundsätzliche um
die frage irgendwie verlangen wir von
der jungen generation die im übrigen
immer früher aus der schule geht und
noch nicht mehr lebensfähig ist also die
ist noch nicht mein sohn wird mit der
nächste wird mit 17 abitur haben der ist
noch nicht bereit das er eigentlich in
die welt entlassen wird die frage ist
also verlangen können wir als
gesellschaft verlangen und zwar würde
ich das durchaus auch mit lohn bezahlen
also es heißt ja ich will ja nicht
irgendwie sklavenarbeiter oder irgendwie
sozusagen außen sollten sie denn geben
ich würde eher sagen wir mal nicht unter
5 600 euro im monat würde ich also ich
finde nicht dass er auch an - und genau
das stört nicht das ist das einzige was
mich stört an der forderung im moment
dass es auch sozusagen die damit dem
pflegenotstand mit allem möglichen
in der regel kriegen die vielleicht 150
euro davon können sie auch als als
junger mensch sich leben also wenn dann
sollte das durchaus finde ich vernünftig
vergütet werden aber dass wir sagen als
gesellschaft jeder gibt auch etwas in
die gesellschaft hinein und ich glaube
dass es für den charakter bildung von
jungen menschen durchaus eine gute sache
ist wenn sie mal ein jahr etwas tun was
sie sich vielleicht gar nicht so sehr
aus suchen aber ich glaube dass sie das
dass das durchaus einen positiven effekt
hat aber ich wäre bei ihnen dass man
keine ausbeutung betreiben soll nach dem
motto wunderbar wir verpflichten jetzt
die jungen menschen weil wir haben
pflegenotstand wir brauchen ein liebes
oder sonst freiwillige soziale ja ich
habe ihn schon für eine verpflichtung
aber für eine die ja nicht zwingend
nicht vergütet werden muss darben ist
würdig ein und bei 69 euro würden
reichen würde sagt ja das
sollten sie auch in der menschen auf
meine debatte ist typisch für unser land
dass wird zuerst gefragt wenn ich etwas
geben soll was gibt mir das stark zurück
und dann ist materiell ich finde das
alter wohnwagen und sarah der
grundkrankheiten unseres landes und
seiner familie sie sagen die familie
heute ist die berufstätige frau das
ideal und der berufstätige man größen da
die familie wo ist denn die zeit sich um
kinder zu kümmern es ist übergegangen
einige fragen sind wie meine kinder
kümmern können die tageslicht in dem
maße wie freundin nicht berufstätig sind
und ich fest überzeugt
ich kenne viele frauen die berufstätig
sind und es gut und da ja ich kann auch
anders
das wahrscheinliche freunde vielleicht
auch die generation habe
ich glaube frau laura 3 und sie dafür
sind sie dagegen dass junge leute
verpflichten das ist ja der punkt der
forderung das freiwillig gibt es ja
schon das dienstjahr
absolvieren sollen für die gemeinschaft
sich in den dienst der gemeinschaft
schaue ich bin ehrlich bin hin und
hergerissen weil also zum einen sehe ich
ursprünglich verfassungsrechtliche
problematik die trotzdem nicht ohne ist
wir haben ja die wehrpflicht ausgesetzt
das ist so nach der verfassung darf man
ja eigentlich keinen arbeitszwang
einführen die ausnahme war die
wehrpflicht und quasi als befreiung
möglichkeit dann der sozialen dienst
allerdings sehe ich auch den vorteil ich
kann nur sagen mein schwager hat damals
sich entschieden in einem altenheim zu
arbeiten oder mobilen pflegedienst der
hat gesagt ich habe sachen gelernt die
hätte ich so nie gesehen und der
profitiert heute noch davon ich war
betreuungs richterin ich bin beruflich
reingeschmissen worden ich hätte mir das
so nicht ausgesucht dadurch lernst du
eine andere sicht auf aller dinge ist
und ich glaube eher haben freiwillige
soziale jahr machen sie es nicht die
dies machen das ist ja jetzt die machen
ja aber wahrscheinlich schon eine eine
soziale ader die haben schon dieses
bewusstsein dass sie auch für die
gesellschaft etwas tun wollen sehr viele
haben dass in den jungen jahren nicht
aber das natürlich schwierig wir
wissen's fdp die leute fehlen als
arbeitskraft das ist natürlich argument
ich sehe auch ihr problematik dass man
sagt wirklich die haben echt jetzt auch
zurück gesteckt das ist ja gerade das
will man dass junge menschen die nicht
die ausbildung haben loslassen in die
sozialen berufe das ist ja oder man ja
auch die anforderung wurde ja die
anforderung und was ich noch fragen
möchte frau land ich fand das heute ganz
spannend ist nicht mein gedanke ich
würde es gerne etwas sagen aber es aber
ich habe in der zeit gelesen da hat
einer autorin gefordert lasst doch die
alten also dass jeder gast dann macht
war aber die eltern kümmern sich doch
jetzt schon um die noch älteren also es
mal ganz ehrlich wer pflegt denn die
meisten wenn zu hause gepflegt zwei
drittel pflegen zu hause und er macht es
denn das machen jetzt mache ich nicht
deutschland nehme aber weil die frau die
mit sich erzählt die eh schon
angeschlagen sind die pflegen auch noch
ihre mutter und ihre schwiegermutter 18
die älteren die älteren herren mit
verlaub die hatten alle noch die
wehrpflicht und haben gedient die haben
eigentlich ihr sommer
malaysia ja
erst ab 70 sofortige
aussetzung bis 70 denn die längere
lebenserwartung die nachweisbar ist
belegbar ist ein zeichen dafür dass auch
gesundheit und fähigkeiten in diesem
also durchaus noch vorhanden sind dann
würden wir nämlich unser rentensystem
ein bisschen ins gewicht regen wir sind
eine wohlfühl und zettel kultur in
diesem land die wir auch jetzt für die
jungen generationen schon wieder kuschen
mein gott ich bin ganz andere meinung
als die frau keller wir haben einen
pflegenotstand der hat auch gründe aber
dann müssen eben in der gesellschaft die
ressourcen mobilisiert werden eine
gesellschaft besteht nicht
und wohin ich sag zum aus nichts möglich
wenn und wenn ich finde dass sie nicht
das recht haben also dass wir auch als
gesellschaft nicht das recht haben
jugendliche sozusagen finanziell
auszubeuten in dem wir sagen wir
verpflichten sie sozusagen und geben
ihnen gar kein ausgleich weil wir würden
ja gleichzeitig parallel im übrigen
erwarten dass die eltern gleichzeitig
diese kinder auch noch ernähren also ich
nehme einfach meine ich habe zwei hört
sie gar nicht
wenn sie meine beiden kinder
verpflichten und denen nur ein
taschengeld geben dann nicht nur leisten
meine kinder dann noch ein ganzes jahr
eine dienstpflicht sondern ich
unterhalte diese kinder auch noch dafür
das heißt auch sie nehmen auch mich in
die pflicht aber was sollte bin ich der
meinung dass er ist eine kompensation
finanziell geben muss ich aber bei ihnen
für die dienstpflicht weil ich glaube
das habe ich
weil ich halt auch nicht hört man im
moment passiert also müsste doch endlich
einmal die realität anschaffen die
dienstpflicht macht allein deswegen
schon gar keinen sinn in der diskussion
weil die anforderungsprofile ganz anders
sind jetzt zu sagen die schicke ich alle
in die pflege pflege hat sich doch in
den letzten 20 30 jahren auch entwickelt
es wird viel digitaler wir wir reden in
im pflege ausschuss über pflege
akademisierung und nicht mehr über die
normalen pflegehelfer das gleiche habe
ich meinem zimmer
gesagt ja das hat sich verändert und
durch die haben nicht wir haben auch
beim thema konnten die situation dass
selbst generell mittlerweile dass es
generell bei der überzeugung sind dass
eine wehrpflicht kann sinn macht das
technische geräte hatte höhere
anforderung ich brauche mir
schulungseinheiten wenn ich die für
zwölf monate habt dann kostet mich das
ausbildung dann kostet mich das
investition aber ich habe im endeffekt
das organisation kann nutzen wenn sie
mir jetzt ein gegenmodell aufmachen wo
wir die gut unterbringen könnten dann
können wir vielleicht sogar noch mal
drüber reden aber dies gibt es nicht das
ist reine das land also in unserer
rücken und herab sondern sie haben
nämlich ihre these mitgebracht so woods
um krieg zu russland und das ist ja auch
nicht
das macht nichts das ist nicht wichtig
es geht nur darum das natürlich ein
aspekt bisher gar nicht erwähnt wurde es
geht auch darum dass alle in der
gesellschaft mal irgendwann während
ihres lebens zusammen kommen und das war
die bundeswehr das war dann der
arbeitersohn der sohn eines
hilfsarbeiters und der soll von mir aus
auch fußball von mir oder sowas sonst
was aber auch der akademika sohn der
unternehmersohn wir werden mal welten
alles super funktioniert mit da wäre ja
ja das ist ja wahnsinnig sich
geschichten von gestern
reden über heute und die gesellschaft
hat heute ihr aber auch viele können da
nicht hin weil das geld kostet und
variierte versuchen sondern hierfür ihre
kind hier irgendwas stadt berlin
aufnahme in einen sportverein zu kriegen
da gibt es die mittel im haushalt wird
und so weiter aber dass wir reden hier
über ein an kleinigkeiten herum der
punkt ist diese gesellschaft hat gemeint
wunde stellen